♪ ♪ ♪
- Cachée au fond d'un fjord,
c'est une île unique
où les rares voisins
se font timides.
Ne cherchez pas de voiture ici.
Le moyen de transport
est le VTT.
Gaultois, pendant des centaines
d'années, a été reconnue
pour la pêche à la morue.
Aujourd'hui, c'est une terre
d'asile pour ceux qui y vivent.
- C'est très tranquille ici,
très paisible. Je me sens bien.
- Dans les années 70, l'usine
de transformation de poissons,
le poumon de l'économie,
a fermé ses portes.
La population est depuis
passée de 600 à 115 personnes.
Année après année,
les maisons se vident.
- Il y avait foule ici quand
nous étions jeunes. C'était
génial! Maintenant, il n'y a
plus d'enfants. On ne les voit
plus jouer dehors, comme avant.
- Sur Gaultois, comme sur
des dizaines d'autres villages
de la province, une menace
plane : la fermeture.
D'autant plus que la province
offre des compensations
financières d'un quart
de million de dollars
par propriétaire pour mettre
la clé sous la porte du village.
C'est 15 fois plus que la valeur
moyenne d'une maison ici.
Montant offert à la condition
que les citoyens organisent
un référendum et que
90 % des résidents soient
d'accord pour accepter l'offre.
La tentation de partir
est forte.
- C'est beaucoup d'argent
pour repartir à neuf, mais ici,
c'est aussi mon chez-moi.
- Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador
est la province la plus
endettée par habitant au pays.
Une offre qui traduit bien
le malaise économique de
la province : couper dans
les services et s'en débarasser.
Les résidents ici ont déjà voté
deux fois et, les deux fois,
près de 80 % d'entre eux
voulaient partir.
Gaultois est déchirée.
Mais voilà qu'arrive
Jane Pitfield, une Ontarienne
venue en vacances 135 fois,
en 10 ans, à Gaultois.
- Hi Gary, how are you?
- Elle n'a pas juste l'air
d'une politicienne; elle l'est.
Élue préfet de la MRC de
Pontiac, au Québec, en 2017,
elle fait des communautés en
déclin son cheval de bataille.
Jane s'est donné comme
mission de sauver ce village.
JANE PITFIELD, femme d'affaires
préfète de la MRC de Pontiac, Qc
- Mon but dans la vie,
c'est de revitaliser
les petites communautés.
Je trouve ça très gratifiant.
- Jane voit grand. Elle a
investi dans une boutique d'art,
une salle de spectacle...
... et elle a aussi
réssucité l'ancien hôtel.
Depuis, il affiche complet
quatre mois par année.
Le conseil municipal est ravi
de voir l'énergie de Jane.
MARCELLA DROVER, greffière
de la municipalité de Gaultois
- J'adore ce qu'elle fait.
J'ai toujours soutenu
les efforts de Jane depuis
son arrivée ici. Je ferai
tout en mon pouvoir pour
continuer à soutenir son impact
communautaire positif.
- Mais personne n'est dupe.
Tout le monde sait que l'île vit
sur le respirateur artificiel.
Même si ceux qui restent font
tout pour que la vie continue.
- G... fifty-seven!
- Bingo pour financer
l'équipe de badminton...
(sirène)
... entraînement des pompiers
volontaire une fois par mois.
La population diminue,
les services aussi, et certains
comme John, atteint de diabète,
devront se rendre à l'évidence.
JOHN WINDSOR, conseiller
municipal de Gaultois
- Quand on vieillit et qu'on a
besoin de plus de soins, on n'a
pas d'autre choix que de partir,
et c'est ce qui se passe,
la population vieillit.
- Le dernier médecin de
Gaultois a fini par déserter.
Une infirmière passe
une fois par mois.
Pour renverser la vapeur,
il faut que de nouvelles
familles viennent s'y installer.
Pour l'instant, Shakira, 6 ans,
est le dernier bébé de l'île.
L'idée d'un bébé tout neuf,
pour Marcella, signifirait
beaucoup d'espoir.
(rire)
- Un nouveau-né, une nouvelle
famille, ce serait parfait
pour garder l'école ouverte.
J'aimerais beaucoup voir
un nouveau bébé ici.
- Pour attirer des jeunes,
il faut des emplois et,
en ce moment, il n'y a
qu'un seul employeur à Gaultois.
Cette ferme d'acquaculture, qui
se situe à environ 10 minutes
de bateau de Gaultois,
emploie environ un tiers
de la population de l'île.
- We've developed hiking paths.
- En plus de vouloir générer
des emplois grâce au tourisme,
Jane a une autre solution et
elle y croit plus que tout :
transformer la défunte usine
en serre hydroponique.
- We are going to have
hydroponic vegetables growing...
- Elle veut fournir
des légumes frais à toutes
les communautés voisines.
Ces rêves sont louables,
mais sont ils suffisants?
Même les derniers jeunes
sont incrédules.
Le doute, on le sent.
Et l'odeur de l'argent
pourrait finir par gagner
ceux qui résistent.
(aboiements)
Jane croit que le gouvernement
réduit la présence sur l'île
à un simple fardeau financier.
Jane croit que le gouvernement
réduit la présence sur l'île
à un simple fardeau financier.
- C'est de la corruption,
pure et simple. Je suis
une politicienne ailleurs
au Canada et je sais que
l'on peut être créatif et plein
de ressources si on le souhaite.
Il faut se battre et protéger
ces communautés pleines
de culture et d'histoire.
Le gouvernement
a baissé les bras.
- Sixty-five!
- Marcella partage les propos
de Jane, et son message
au gouvernement est clair.
- Vous payez les infrastructures
et les services pour tous
les résidents de la province et,
nous ici, nous sommes résidents
au même titre que les autres.
Je paie des taxes; je mérite
les mêmes services.
- Une dizaine de villages
ont accepté la proposition
du gouvernement,
mais Jane persiste.
- J'espère et je crois
que la ville de Gaultois
a un bon futur.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Celle qui repart chaque
fois avec ses promesses
n'arrêtera devant rien.
Gaultois la glorieuse,
comme on l'appelle,
pourra-t-elle résister?
Ici Elisa Serret,